[Music]
what is up everybody
Anna Mack here for anime uproar and
welcome to our attack on Titan chapter
108 review in this chapter we didn't
have a lot of action but we definitely
had a lot of intrigue so I can't wait to
talk about it and if you've been
watching our reviews for the last
several chapters my brother goes in was
handling those reviews we sometimes
switch out depending on what projects
were working on but goes and we'll pop
in at the end of this video to share
some of your comments from social media
also recently we organized I create your
own my hero academia character contest
here on the channel where we asked you
guys to submit ideas for a new character
within the world of boku no hero a
character with their own unique work and
backstory after over a thousand
submissions we chose the winner live
during our weekly podcast rant cafe and
we paid a professional artist to bring
the winning design to life synchro by
gravity falls
this first contest was so successful
that we are going to launch another one
this week but this time something tells
me that the contest will be about
creating your own attack on titan
character and more specifically creating
your own titan shifter with its own
unique appearance powers and abilities
now of course those of us who read the
manga know who the nine Titan shifters
are but if there were 10 and you could
design the 10th what would he or she
look like and what would be his or her
power to participate in this contest
follow us on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar and we will announce all
the details soon just like last time the
winning design will be brought to life
by a professional artist and of course
if you enjoyed the attack on titan
content on this channel if you liked
these reviews be sure to leave a like to
let me know and if you're new to the
channel don't forget to subscribe and
colossal smash that notification bell
now as the chapter starts off we see
that Pyxis and the garrison appear to
have betrayed aaron and the survey corps
by going behind their back and detaining
all of the volunteers who came from are
laid to fight for parodies this is my
impression anyway I feel like the
garrison is working behind
the back of the survey Corps I don't
think they were aware of exactly what
was happening and I think that the
reason why Levi and some of the members
of the survey Corps took Zeke into the
Titan forest was most likely to keep him
out of the hands of the military
although they still wanted to be on a
terrain that would be advantageous to
them in case Zeke decided to stab them
in the back to be honest betrayals are
realistic and happen all the time in war
and politics and attack on titan is
great and reminding us of that during
the conversation between the soldiers
you can definitely see where the
garrison soldiers are coming from they
now know that the power of the founding
Titan can manipulate their memories so
basically their entire lives can in
theory be controlled by a totalitarian
ruler if that ruler has royal blood and
the founding Titan power from this
perspective it makes perfect sense for
the soldiers to be worried and for them
to want to be extra careful about who
they trust with such incredible power
they just don't know Zeke well enough to
trust him and since he has royal blood
he could definitely become a massive
threat to everyone who is a subject of
Amir because if he gets the founding
Titan power he could manipulate all of
their memories moving on to historia
she seems to have gotten pregnant
willingly at this particular time but
what is their reason was it really to
avoid becoming a Titan or to save Zeke
from being eaten as some of the members
of the garrison seemed to believe or did
historia decide to get pregnant at this
specific time because she believes that
having a royal heir as soon as possible
is the best strategy and is the story of
who the father is
even true I couldn't help but think this
while I was reading the chapter but how
convenient is that that the father just
happens to be a completely harmless
nobody just someone from history as
childhood who wouldn't draw any
attention by the military or anyone else
someone who is not a threat to anyone
from what we see historian definitely
doesn't seem very happy in her
interactions with the alleged fathers so
is he the true father or is there more
going on here could it be that historian
is working together with Aaron and Zeke
on a secret plan that the military
doesn't know about the military sure
doesn't seem to trust historian so is it
possible that she doesn't trust them
either now we don't actually know this
to be the case but I was thinking what
if having both parents have royal blood
means that the child that they produce
will be even more powerful as a Titan
could it be that maybe Zeke and historia
have gotten together quite literally to
give the island there's the strongest
possible ruler in the future that could
be interesting although I'm not
necessarily betting on it and another
thing that I was thinking is could the
entire pregnancy be false and historia
is only pretending to be pregnant in
order to keep the army from forcing her
to eat Zeke I don't know if anyone from
the military actually physically
examined historia or if they are just
taking her word for it that she's
pregnant so could she be faking that
she's pregnant just to advance some plan
or could she be pregnant but with
someone else's child and we don't know
the true father or is this guy from her
childhood really the father and there's
nothing more to the story his story his
whole attitude towards this definitely
makes me doubtful she doesn't seem at
all happy to be with this guy from her
childhood but she decided to have
children with him it seems a little bit
strange at any rate this is all shaping
up to be a very interesting episode of
the Maury show so we'll have to stick
around and find out what happens next
and speaking of potential secret plans
what are Erin and Zeke's true intentions
and how will they work together to
harness the founding Titan even Erin's
closest friends are unsure about Aaron
and why he is so committed to Zeke's
plan to the point that he decided to act
on his own with the mission to Marlay
and some Aaron's closest friends
including Connie seem to think that
Aaron is not who he once was that he
changed and this could be a consequence
of consuming more Titan powers and with
them the memories of many other people
not to mention that the scene in which
Han Jie saw Erin talking to himself in
the mirror could be a sign that all the
different memories jumbled up inside him
are having a negative psychological
effect on him and changing him as goals
and mentioned in the previous video
Mikasa of course believes that Aaron is
doing what he has to do for them his
closest friends because they are the
people who are the most precious to him
in the entire world but the question
remains after consuming more Titan
powers is Eren the same person too
he once was the military doesn't seem to
trust him and they seem to have betrayed
him and Zeke by putting their own plans
into motion but on top of that we see
that even among Aaron's closest friends
there are doubts about whether he can
still be trusted Arman wants to confirm
Aaron's true intentions and prove that
Aaron is still on their side as does
Mikasa of course but others including
Connie and John are having serious
doubts on the international scene the
nation of his uru seems only interested
in the resources on parodies and wants
to manipulate the Islanders for their
own benefit they want the LD ins and
parodies to demonstrate their power to
the world by using some of the wall
Titans which would of course make the
whole world scared of them and this
would mean that he's uru is the only
nation able to access parodies and
communicate with other nations on behalf
of parodies Ezra wants a monopoly and
all the resources and trade with the
island and I think that they also want
the Mikasa in order to legitimize their
own regime with their own people so they
seem to be mostly interested in just
using parodies as a pawn for their own
interests members of the sûreté Corps
seem to have figured this out and have
been looking for an alternative solution
in recent years a way to show the world
that they want peace otherwise they fear
that the island is going to have a war
forced upon them and that they will be
forced to use the wall Titans even if
they don't want to I really like this
harsh reality that the Islanders are
facing because this is exactly what
international politics looks like there
are no genuine friends and allies in
international politics there are only
interests and every nation is always
trying to exploit the other nations in
order to gain the most for themselves as
a student of politics including
international relations I have to say
that attack on Titan has one of the most
mature nuanced and realistic
perspectives on politics that I've seen
in any manga we then see that Gabby and
Falco entered a wooded area to hide
after escaping from prison when Falco
tries to take off Gabby's LD an armband
telling her that she's drawing too much
attention to herself if she keeps it on
she actually resists saying that she is
a good LDN and taking off the armband
will mean that she will become the same
as the so-called Devils on the island
and as annoyed as we all are with
B's self-hatred and masochistic behavior
we have to remember that she is still
just a child who was brainwashed her
whole life to believe this propaganda I
mean just look at how long it took
Reiner to realize that things weren't
right and that he was being lied to
with that said we are definitely seeing
the story progressed towards Gabby
understanding the truth Falco points out
that the guard Gabby attacked in order
to make their escape was genuinely
concerned about her well-being and while
on the run they meet a girl who kindly
offers them food even though they are
complete strangers these types of
occurrences are definitely going to
humanize the Islanders for Gabby and
Falco and it is clear that Falco already
seems to understand that the Islanders
are not the terrible people that they
were made out to be some theories are
already popping up and stating that the
girl who finds Falco and Gabby in the
woods is the same girl that Sasha
rescued from a Titan years ago and that
through this girl Gabby will ultimately
realize that Sasha and many of the other
Islanders are actually good people
knowing ISA Amma this is definitely
possible because for him everything
always connects in the end
in the final scene we learned that the
Marlin army knows that Zeke faked his
death and that he has been secretly
working against Marlay for years the
plan is to assemble a massive army of
Allied nations who all witnessed the
horrific power of the Titans at the
festival and to attack the island within
six months implementing a scorched earth
policy meaning destroying everything and
everyone but Reiner is determined to act
sooner because he thinks Zeke will be
planning something before six months
have passed but also probably because he
knows that Falco and Gabby will likely
be killed in a scorched earth attack
Gabby and Falco have little to no value
for Marlene now so unless there is a
rescue operation before the big attack
Gabby and Falco are probably as good as
dead but beyond that we know that Reiner
knows the truth about the Islanders and
that he is sick of fighting so we can't
just assume that he is suddenly back to
being a committed warrior he might have
his own plan to stop the war and the
killing of so many innocent people a
plan that may or may not involve Aaron
and
and that is why he insists on going to
the island as soon as possible but let
me know what you guys think is Aaron
still the same person or did consuming
the titan powers change him just like
every member of the royal family he
seems to change after they inherit the
founding titan and suddenly they accept
the 145th king's ideology also what
exactly are Aaron and Zeke planning and
our Aaron's friends going to betray him
finally do you think that Reiner is
really back to being a committed warrior
of Marlay or is he planning something
else let me know down in the comments
don't forget to follow us on twitter and
instagram at anim uproar to participate
in the create your own attack on titan
character contests thanks Anna Mac and
now goes in here with some of your
predictions from last chapter so a
number of you on instagram guests that
we get to find out who historians baby's
father is and in this chapter they did
in fact reveal who the father is at
least if we believe that we are being
told the truth on Twitter go stalker
predicted we'd catch up with Gabi and
Falco we definitely did I actually
thought that that scene was pretty
significant you never know with Gabi but
the fact that Falco tore off her
armbands seems to symbolize that she
will not be as brainwashed from this
point forward that armband symbolized
the prejudice and internalized racism
that they faced in Marlay so the fact
that it's been removed even though it
was against Gabby's will seems to
foreshadow her making progress and
starting to see that the Islanders are
not that different from her I mean she
even says that if she loses the armband
she will become like the devil's of the
island so on some level she realizes
that clearly there isn't that much of a
difference between a good albion and an
evil LD and if one armband is all that's
separating them plus she didn't killed
that innocent girl with a rock which is
definitely progress for Gabby next go
stalker again but this time he travelled
the vast Internet in order to leave a
message on our Instagram asks what is
the biggest mystery that me and Anna mac
want to know about an attack on Titan
which is a great question by the way for
Anna Mac he is most curious of
how yamir the first Jameer actually got
her Titan powers for me right now I'm
really curious about how Kruger was able
to mention Mikasa and Armin before they
were born I am fascinated by this
apparent ability that allows the attack
titan user and perhaps other Titan users
to get glimpses into the future I
definitely want to see how that will be
explained in future chapters and how it
might come to play in the story and the
bonus one is one that I hear from you
guys a lot in the comments what would
happen if all nine Titan powers were in
one person I am really curious about
this and I know a lot of you are as well
if you have any theories about any of
these mysteries definitely leave them
below in the comments I really like this
question so feel free to leave us more
questions to answer on this videos
Instagram or Twitter post and we may
address them in the next chapter review
anyways guys that's it for this video as
always thanks so much for watching and
supporting this channel it means a lot
to us if you liked this video give it a
colossal Warhammer smash if you haven't
subscribe and ring that bell to join the
notification na kama until next time see
you space cowboys
[Music]